مع إن الحواسيب الكمية ما راح تكون مناسبة لحل
كل المشكلات، في بعض فئات المشكلات
وحالات الاستخدام المحتملة اللي نتوقع
الحوسبة الكمية تأثر فيها.
هذه تشمل المحاكاة مثل
نمذجة العمليات والأنظمة اللي تحصل في
الطبيعة، والبحث والتحسين
اللي يشمل البحث عن أفضل
أو الحل الأمثل في موقف فيه
إجابات كثيرة محتملة، والرياضيات
ومعالجة البيانات ذات البنية المعقدة
بما فيها تطبيقات التعلم الآلي.
الخوارزميات الكمية تتبع نهجاً جديداً في
هذا النوع من المشكلات، وتستغل
الخصائص الفريدة لفيزياء الكم زي
التراكب والتداخل والتشابك الكمي.
الحواسيب العادية تتعثر
وهي تستكشف مناطق معينة في الفضاء الحسابي
فما تقدر تلقى هذه الأنماط.
الحواسيب الكمية مجهزة بـ
قدرات إضافية أو أداء أعلى
لبعض المشكلات بفضل طبيعتها الكمية.
عشان تفهم إمكانيات الحواسيب الكمية بشكل كامل
لازم تتعمق في نظرية تعقيد الحوسبة،
وهي فرع من علوم الحاسوب يركز على
قياس ومقارنة الجهد الحسابي اللي
يتطلبه حل أنواع مختلفة من المشكلات.
هذا يوفر إطاراً مفيداً
لوصف تسريعات متعددة
وفئات المشكلات اللي نصادفها في
الحوسبة.